let's do [ __ ] [ __ ] alright do
any of you guys watch sports and have
any of your sports been affected by the
whole corona quarantines doesn't that
all sports well football season hasn't
started to get o true but my team makes
it made some horrible draft picks so I
don't know hmm
sports sports but I watch the occasional
basketball game and I know that was
postponed yes so the Florida sport can
be okay it's an endurance yes sports so
the NBA 2020 there is a season update
which people are very excited about
because they had to stop all of it so
here's a bunch of questions a frequently
asked questions section if you will if
you guys are wondering if the NBA is
coming back so the first question is can
NBA teams practice right now so in case
you're wondering the NBA team facilities
are now open for individual workouts but
they got to do a one player to one coach
system oh that's enough you can't do P
but it's all about team yeah they're
gonna do basketball season at the same
time we'll see I don't know but so the
second question is when all the NBA
start playing games again there's no
actual return date but they've been
thinking about July 31st is that close
to football season close it starts in
September usually oh damn scheduled play
the World Series is usually October oh
so like it's baseball season's coming to
an end during that time but people stop
watching baseball yeah
so what's crazy about the NBA is uh you
know I think a lot of people aren't if
you have guys been following like
getting a white but he was super adamant
about making sure to keep pushing the
UFC and he was gonna have a fight Island
finally found a venue in Florida Florida
consider sports an essential like
business for industry Florida is crazy
so like Pete I think since these are
such giant industries they want to make
sure they keep going
so the NBA they're most potential site
right now is Walt Disney World in
Orlando Florida because the whole thing
is a private place
they're gonna put all of the players
light into one hotel and they'll only
play in one place so instead of like
what kind of rivalry are is gonna happen
in that hotel instead of like the Lakers
going to New York to play the Knicks or
in a play like the Spurs or whatever
it's everyone's gonna be at one place
and they're gonna play in only one place
with no fans yeah no offense we're gonna
see all these ballers riding roller
coaster ride lucky so they're calling
this a bubble site where they're it's
everyone's quarantine in the same area
everyone's gonna be tested everyone's
gonna have the same exact regulations
and like the way that the game the
people practice before the game or after
the game it's gonna be completely the
same and since it's a private property
they could run the whole thing the way
that they want to so they feel like it's
gonna be the safest way to do it which
is pretty nuts because they're saying
that if they cut out the entire season
the entire basketball industry will lose
a billion dollars but if they do this
they only lose like what a hundred
million or do they they didn't say they
didn't say but what they're saying is
what could be really cool is if they can
actually kind of like truncate the whole
season now because before it'd be like
like you know when you have finals it's
like this team goes here plays two games
they gotta put in travel time they come
over here Malaysia games now since
everyone is together just play
back-to-back just truncate the entire
season let's go back to that time is
that all athletes they're like a whole
MBA so I think the ones that they're
saying are the ones that made the
playoffs we'll go there so there's gonna
be a couple of eight eight teams from
each conference is gonna go that's
pretty cool I also feel like that's just
like all the boys get a kick in a hotel
room I find the guy have hella fun yeah
that's true or it's gonna be like a
pageant system in the backstage is there
gonna be sabotaging each other cable
down and they didn't have like the
cameras like Laval ah so sick make it a
reality TV show show and nation you'll
be late too since there's no like crowds
they should switch up the camera angles
like get more cinematic like half
cameras
the court hears a second all the other
teams in the stands just talking won't
start making their free-throws because I
don't have the [ __ ] no one that
distract them so here's are the teams
where Western Conference you got the
Lakers Clippers Nuggets Jazz Thunder
Rockets Mavericks please Trail Blazers
pelicans King Spurs in the Suns that's
gonna be Western Eastern Conference
never expects Raptors Celtics Heat
Pacers 76ers nets magic and wizards yeah
that was the laughter that Jordan was on
Canada oh no that's a Raptors right ders
yeah oh that's the last team Jordan with
them mm-hmm wait isn't that Utah
Washington Washington I know that
because I'm reading you're not supposed
to read what he doesn't have the black
screen on so yeah Dan on the Wizards can
gonna hear Potter ride that's a great on
the road that's true cuz they said what
happens if a player test positive for
Kovan 19 I'll like I've shut down the
whole team no they're just gonna
quarantine that player and then put that
guy away everything you track of
everything he touch you know I guess not
use testing when Allison I'd be like no
one's gonna have Cove it but like it's
gonna be crazy with all the STI is that
everyone catches from all the females
the invites of the hotel well they'll be
checked I'm sure they're gonna be like
really really tight I've been following
that UFC and then I think to catch up
they had like three or four ufc's in one
week and it was all in Florida and then
people don't even know they're
asymptomatic they don't know if you have
Corona or whatever right so they get
tested they stink that crazy swab thing
up their nose Dana White himself got
tested like every single times but there
was this one guy and I felt bad for him
because he arrived there and he actually
tested positive and so he didn't get to
fight which makes sense but I'm like man
when you put in 12 13 14 weeks until if
I can and then when you make weight
could you got cut like 15 20 pounds of
water only to get there and test
positive
like [ __ ] kind of sucks crazy I mean I
think at that point it's like though
like the whole roads kind of going
through it yeah as I get few fives and
he's also infecting someone know
something else so I think it's like it
sucks but it's like if they want to
continue that's the steps that they had
to take you know it's also how you paid
pizzas family to which kind of sucks but
I get it you know but he's also [ __ ]
up the person edifice yeah
like literally would shut down the whole
organization cool yeah I was getting now
so they're a couple of Lakers or like
just some star players davender and yeah
the guy that something-something Gobert
he like touched all the microphones
because he was like here's like a good
time and then like literally the next
day he tests positive for but she go the
microphone I don't know how he got it
felt like he wasn't making fun of covin
right before you were that kid that like
look the airplane seat or somehow my god
yeah I don't know if they died I just
heard about it okay wasn't that what
that was a lady
tick-tock or no yeah I was like they're
trying to start the Cova challenge or
something and they like lick the
airplane see and they're getting it and
they got yeah they got it I don't know
if they died okay you guys hear about
how cities might not be as populated
anymore because you know how like all
these big companies are saying like you
could work from home now so people just
went back to like the suburbs are like
wherever yeah they just stay there now
like like when NY went crazy a lot of
people just left huh City yeah and
they're like yeah we still have our jobs
right a lot of our transplants anyways
yeah and so now they don't they realize
they could do all their work from home
and they don't have to be in the office
and companies are like I don't want to
pay rent for this big-ass high-rise
building yeah I would love people would
get the hell out of LA the way that we
can get around right now oh it's amazing
awesome it was kind of weird at first
like driving on LA and having no traffic
like this is kind of eerie
yeah then now I'm like oh this is
amazing I can get to the studio in 20
minutes yeah and then I see like two
extra cars on the freeway like
[ __ ] would you be thinking a
little more cluttered is like full
traffic I'm like what the [ __ ] like
opening again yeah
like damn I miss it I miss people the
second I gotta tell ya miss people trap
it I thought I did until I got in
traffic I never would you never miss
traffic well you know cuz they deem like
he's lunch and he's in the traffic and
hopefully he's like waiting everybody I
feel like comforted there's people I
grew up in the Bay Area so we had
traffic since all the kid you know I'll
go you guys to in LA yeah I thought la
had bad traffic until I went to San
Francisco and I'm like damn this shit's
crazy horrible to get into the city some
of the season through flowers what yeah
y'all got the bad like Street traffic
yeah yeah yeah like New York yeah that's
in the city mmm well if you go to like
just like the suburbs it's fine I'm just
getting on the highway I was in San
Francisco and I was running out of gas
and I could see the Chevron but it was
just moving so slow that I'm like [ __ ]
I'm gonna run out of gas before I even
pull into the gas station because the
thing was already red yeah did you make
it I made it you know like driving
without traffic is dope but I just I I
am kind of ready to just go to a real
restaurant and sit down and yeah do you
think it's gonna get even crazier
because now everyone's gonna have that
FOMO and want to go out yeah that's what
I'm scared of like there's gonna be like
way too many people out yeah I feel like
people are paranoid yeah so there's
gonna be the half word there like I
can't wait [ __ ] it I just I'm just gonna
do it and I think there's the other half
that's kind of like nah there's gonna be
a second wave I'm gonna I want to wait
another month after like they're like
hey it's open good to go I'm gonna wait
for maybe like three or four weeks just
wait there yeah I'm good I'll go to the
gym but I'll probably wear like
restaurants and bars you're gonna wait a
month after we open to go to a
restaurant yeah like sushi or something
oh so you got a weed out the what so you
want them to diapers what are you
waiting for
it's like the month is gonna happen and
they're like actually we made a mistake
people are getting sick and you're like
thank God and go out is that what you're
waiting for
but then I'ma be like yes I got my sushi
one time I'm with you either either
they're gonna be like it's okay or they
do me like oh we're saying again still
stay home and also I just want to see
what the temperatures like because I
don't like crowded areas anyway so if
everyone's all out cuz you know they
opened up Wisconsin I think it was and
like immediately all the bars were
packed yeah
I'm not trying to be in a crowd yeah bro
so if if there's just crowded
restaurants everywhere I'm like oh we
being an early adopter for this is kind
of like a death sentence potentially
what if you just go to places that
already had it so then you like move on
or whatever you're like ah you know they
had it okay you know how Europe is
starting to open up because they had it
now they're opening up so like are you
cool with getting on a plane right now I
don't know if I could go on a plane yeah
you yeah I kind of want to go oh yeah
well Japan has a thing where they're
actually gonna start like helping cover
fees and certain things because they
want to increase the tour
tourism I feel like I already get sick
on planes like I already feel sick every
time I travel and now there's like
emergency added layer it cuz that
recycled air it's just so like I'm
assuming that since everyone's afraid to
travel right now it's the best time
because it's it's there's enough time
that passed that's what I'm thinking
business oh there's gonna be like barely
buddy on their planes been corn super
sanitized yeah now they're cleaning it
like crazy yeah everyone's wearing a
face masks and yeah like if we go to
Vegas now it's gonna be the cleanest
that Vegas everyone immediately a week
after it's black back to you disgusting
I just come everywhere yeah you gotta
pick your connecting flights better you
get the one to Wuhan so the one's gonna
be on that one
[Music]
[Music]